j'ai deux petites surprises qu'on a mais
euh je vous le dis puisque il ya une
personne qui est venue me voir ce soir
pour m'annoncer quelque chose je vous le
dis il ya un ami qui est là il a quelque
chose à vous annoncer
est ce que vous voulez le voir tout de
suite mérite à nancy 1-2 suite d'autres
sites ou tard tout de suite dit oui
c'est une grande nouvelle qui va
bouleverser le paf
ohé nord 6 ohlala six mois je vais voir
tout de suite mais qui va venir me voir
moi j'aime bien de bouleverser gad
proposé mme wade wilson star louis star
américaine presque gazon américain
est ce que c'est un frère oui c'est un
frère un acteur un frère richetin
l'acteur est ce qu'il est petit non
moins de 40
oui est-ce qu'il est drôle oui est ce
qu'il est la barre c'est son nom ce qui
est inquiétant mais pas ou venant il n'y
a pas une barre debout mais si les
jeunes ou pas ce qu'est une touffe
il faut d'abord une touffe latine il en
a partout à votre avis est ce qu'il est
marié
non est ce qu'on a vu dans un film
méfiance et oui on le roule on le voit
tout le temps est ce que c'est un don
joint y avait un penchant pour les miss
france oui
[Applaudissements]
écoutez mes frérot mais j'adore non mais
lorsque je suis au tout et que vous
m'ayez trouvé sur sa faim toute chose
qui me définit témoin qui d'abord et
avant tout trouvé akinator on parle
commenté trouver dans qui l'attend en
direct je vais voir tout de suite les
villes le yoga avec un petit mot
barbichette direz vous akinator et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont trouvé est-ce qu'il a
bien aimé ce compte là mes frères c'est
pas la question c'est le maire jouer
allez c'est parti je le fais en direct
avec les téléspectateurs et les
personnages est il un gars au oui oui
attention ton personnage est une réelle
ou si c'est oui ton personnage ça fait
plus de trente ans non et non je vais
les avoir dans sept mois très bien ok
ton personnage est il décédé
non personnage fétiche de la politique
non et non attention ton personnage et
il célèbre wii ordaz alors ton
personnage est il français
oui je pense aux gens qui sont en train
d'allumer la télé 18h20 personnage est
il dans le domaine de la musique n'ont
rien mis du temps quand même
et là qu'il a tort elle est moins fort
que nous ton personnage travil
travaille-t-il sur une chaîne de télé
dit oui nous ne trouvait toi frais on va
dire tôt car cela j'ai dit le
présentateur sur tf1 non non non mais
non mais bon non ce qu'ils pensent un
présentateur là on est dans la merde on
va durer
vous êtes dans la deuxième partie des
berges et il a ilbo doit-on mon
personnage fait-il partie de la faillite
mais le leinster la liste et lanester
attentes sur ton personnage c'est il
n'agit pas assez les questions qui
d'accord me demande elle son personnage
c'est une magie non non c'est toi c'est
la chute
oui son personnage et il présentateur
télé non à la il va soit il va te
trouver il va te trouver non at il dit
notant pascal et bambi est ce que ton
personnage est un humoriste je suis sûr
bombe heiko maas ton personnage at il
parfois quelque chose sur son dos franck
la non mais les questions sont folles
attention akinator on vit en direct des
décès de lancer dans un hacker nador on
dirait un jour je crois regardez et moi
de ton personnage c'est une marié six
fois non c'est pas une mamie à la
société qnx un chrono
ces grandes bananeraies j'aime beaucoup
ce style lunettes je te le dis je sais
j'aime beaucoup
alors ça ne s'est pas simplement
lunettes ses lunettes teintées ouais ça
donne un style un peu tu vois ambiance
mais mystérieux quand même bien sûr mon
chéri dis moi demain et je sais qu'à
être envoyé plein de messages août et
oui demain soir lembras d'un samedi 30
janvier à 21h il ya quelques add and
friends exa direct du free du comédien
nouveau lieu de l'humour à paris il ya
qu'à madame c'est gad elmaleh qui
donnent rendez vous à leurs amis
humoristes
alors il y aura plein de mondiale belge
sabine je kiffe romane freyssinet que je
surkiffe samuel bobby que j'adore elie
semoun
exceptionnellement il ya du viaduc star
game à bouder il ya plein plein de plein
d'humour qui tue on se réunit tous
demain soir sur la scène du fritsch et
en streaming live c'est la nouvelle
manière et malheureusement la seule
manière aujourd'hui de faire du
spectacle on a pensé à le faire en
cliquant une collecte mais c'est une
galère tu là il vient d'où mais l
excellent et tu nous avais une petite
surprise et je vous ai n'est en fait si
jamais été chocolatier série je vous
aurais aimé des petits chocolats tu
viens de te prendre la vitre lézardée
chocolat ça parce que de retour des
chocolatines vraiment ils prennent un
truc de chocolat tout court ah ouais bah
oui non là donc je pense à cause du
chocolat donc oui si chocolat là comme
demain on fait un stream je vous ai
amené un petit extrait il vous amener un
humoriste il m'a dit mon rêve s'est
passé vers tp de kif et donc il y là il
a un style je le laisse se présenter
lui-même et c'est un honneur pour moi de
vous le présenter et il sera sur le
plateau demain quelle gare elle freine
en streaming
il reste des places on pourrait acheter
des places il reste des places mais
c'est illimité passer sa motion où il a
vécu et d'internet
exactement s'il vous plaît faites par
action il a les cheveux que j'avais fait
un maximum de bruit pour alex vrai don
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très très content à la clé et là
surprise pour vous à alors j'ai une
surprise je te kiffe alex s et rigolé t
j'adore parce que c'est j'adore la
coiffure tu me fais penser un mec qui
croyaient que moi cédric l'info un mec
qui travaille après avec arthur et
qu'est ce qu'il peut et qu'arthur
d'entre eux vous perdre beaucoup de
jacques chirac il a tort à l'extrême la
manière dont je me présente sur scène
j'ai que comme vous le constatez je suis
le fils de ramzi et michel berger ouais
c'est vrai alors c'est pas de semafo
qu'on embrasse mon chéri voilà voilà
héhé je vous ai pris une petite surprise
au lieu de vous faire un petit sketch
comme je vais faire demain soir a fait
un truc exprès pour chez nous pour vous
moi j'aime bien faire des petites
chansons comme ça à l'improviste comme
ça donc je vous ai fait une chance pour
elle c'est sa spécialité
voilà fait des chansons comme ça
rigolote quoi j'ai couché avec beaucoup
de meuf comme savoir si un voile a way
des chansons sur des moeurs et qu' il a
fait un petit coup de langue
alors si ça fait plaisir alors que
martin petit succès sur le site youtube
avant tout à découvrir
daf l'eau on est tous
confiné heureusement qu'il ya tpm pays
sinon se feraient vraiment chier on
serait tous devant arte heureusement
qu'à 20 jamin castaldi comme j'aime ta
engagée si j'ai bien compris mr peu cher
pour pas que tu prennes du poids ça leur
aurait coûté moins cher de m'engager moi
d'être année et vous le voyez pas mais
en dessous ce jean il ya un autre jean
pourtant je mange un parfois j'ai
l'impression que toute la nourriture que
j'avale bas c'est juste de l'engrais
pour mes cheveux en plaine heureusement
qu'à kehl iv novelli toujours souriante
est super jolie inc
chacun se faire remarquer à sa façon
regarde les vêtements de guillaume
genton allait encore chez soir ellison
si ça arrive et ça va toujours y faire
heureusement qu'à isabelle maureen cyril
n'arrête pas dire que tu vieillis non
non au début je
récemment messi et toi non plus tu n'a
plus 20 ans puis de chair vient pas plus
j'aurais pu parler des autres chroniques
a battu pau mais je suis perdu ça change
tout en chroniqueur change un habitué
je ne leur vois plus la semaine d'après
on est tous confinés
heureusement qu'il ya tpm pays sinon se
feraient vraiment chier on serait tous
devant matt et ensemble on est tous
compilés passé la casse et heureusement
sinon ce sera tous merci merci et bravo
à vous merci vous avez vraiment
contribuer au succès moi je connaissais
la mia guillaumin mais non mais non mais
t'as jamais réussi à le dire un peu dj
snake de wisches mais j'aime qui nous
reçoit dans une maison et on regardera
demande si bien entendu j'espère garder
ou demain ça nous fera plaisir vos
esprits chez vous comédie 11 points live
où je peux vos billets et on va faire
tout ce voilà des petits sketchs avait
toute une soirée a été annoncée hier à
notre frère oggad évidemment il y aura
des frérots gad et puis on vous parlera
de planeur a goûté aux abonnés il y aura
plein planète franchement plein d'humour
hisser un plateau exceptionnel me direz
le marrakech du rire tellement c'est
abdelhak hélas le futur anzhi à ibiza
ça on va se calmer on va commencer par
soit vacciné je fais partie des gens
priorité merci en tout cas et si je peux
me permettre parce que je propose parce
que je suis un peu pas connu en fait tu
vois donc ouais si j'en suis pour nous
si si si vous voulez me rajouter sur un
star alex fredo a fait un rodéo ça fera
plaisir c'est show biz à on se parle sur
les données du beau frère ont jeté des
fleurs